Estoy seguro de que si os preguntara qué
es la OTAN, la gran mayoría me sabría decir
de manera clara lo que es:
Una alianza militar entre diferentes países
que se creó para hacer frente a la antigua
Unión Soviética.
De hecho, la OTAN, la Organización del Tratado
del Atlántico Norte, ya cuenta con 31 países
aliados, 32 con Suecia.
Es decir, hablamos, con mucha diferencia,
de la mayor alianza militar de todo el mundo.
Y desde luego creo que todos conocemos el
poder militar de muchos de los ejércitos
de los países que integran este club.
Sin ir más lejos, ahí tenemos a los todopoderosos
Estados Unidos de América.
Pero ¿y si os dijera que en la OTAN hay un
país que no tiene ejército?
Seguramente os preguntaríais: ¿cómo puede
haber un país sin ejército en una alianza
militar como la OTAN?
Pues sí, este es el caso de nuestro protagonista
de hoy: Islandia.
En efecto, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
esta lejana isla entre Europa y América con
apenas 370.000 habitantes y que subsiste principalmente
gracias, la fundición de aluminio, la pesca
y el turismo, es el único país de la OTAN
que no tiene ejército.
De hecho, muchos piensan que esta es la principal
razón de que Islandia sea el país más pacífico
del mundo.
Un puesto que lleva ostentando más de una
década.
Pero os estaréis preguntando: ¿cómo es
posible que no tenga ejército?
Desde luego no es el primer país ni será
el último en no tener fuerzas armadas: en
el mundo hay más de 30 países que no las
tienen.
Hablamos de lugares como Andorra, Mónaco
o Panamá, todos ellos son países con poca
población.
Sin embargo, lo lógico sería pensar que
si un país está dentro de una alianza militar
es porque un ejército propio.
¿No os parece?
¿Y sabéis que es lo más sorprendente de
todo?
Qué durante mucho Islandia fue un miembro
importante de la OTAN.
¿Cómo es esto posible?
Pues veréis, a pesar de que Islandia no tenga
fuerzas armadas, el país cuenta con otro
activo tremendamente valioso: su posición
geográfica.
De hecho, ya durante la Guerra Fría se convirtió
en uno de los territorios más codiciados
por las grandes super-potencias.
Pero ¿por qué?
¿Qué tiene de importante su localización
en el mapa mundial?
¿Cómo ha logrado Islandia sacar provecho
de su ubicación?
¿Quién defiende a esta remota isla en caso
de ser atacada o incluso invadida?
¿Qué papel juega en un Ártico cada vez
más militarizado por Rusia?
Pues hoy vamos a responder a todas estas preguntas
y otras más.
Así que, sin más preámbulo, vamos con ello.
Arranquemos.
(EL PODER DE LA GEOGRAFÍA)
Os hago una pregunta.
¿Qué es lo primero que se os viene a la
cabeza si os pregunto por Islandia?
¿Quizás los vikingos?
¿Quizás volcanes cuyas cenizas pueden llegar
a paralizar Europa?
Pues sí, cualquie ra de estas dos cosas son
muy características de esta isla pero, al
margen de eso, habl amos de un país que normalmente
ha pasado bastante desapercibido a lo largo
de la historia moderna.
Al fin y al cabo, históricamente fue una
lejana isla del Reino de Dinamarca, desolada
por la pobreza, las hambrunas, las epidemias
e incluso por alguna que otra erupción volcánica.
Sin embargo, el destino de este lugar empezaría
a cambiar a mitad del siglo pasado, cuando
Reino Unido, primero y luego Estados Unidos,
ocuparon la isla entre 1940 y 1944 para hacer
frente a la Alemania nazi en el norte del
océano Atlántico.
Para los islandeses fue inevitable, ya que
en 1869 abolieron su propio ejército.
El caso es que con el tiempo y sobre todo
en el siglo XX, Islandia se convirtió en
un punto estratégico, y eso era algo que
Estados Unidos tenía muy claro.
Por este motivo, el Tío Sam pronto comenzó
a negociar con Islandia su entrada a la OTAN.
(Conseguida su independencia en 1944, Islandia
fue rápidamente consciente de su privilegiada
posición geoestratégica como vigilante del
norte del Atlántico.
Y a parte de eso, en Reikiavik también tenían
muy presente la ocupación extranjera de la
isla y su indefensión.
Así que el movimiento era claro: convertirse,
junto a otros países europeos, Estados Unidos
y Canadá, en miembro fundado r de la OTAN,
que pasaría a ser uno de los pilares fundamentales
de su defensa.
Sin embargo, tras el comienzo de la guerra
de Corea, el miedo en la isla a ser atacado
por la Unión Soviética se disparó.
Islandia necesitaba efectivos militares en
la isla urgentemente.
Por eso, en 1951 cerró un acuerdo de defensa
con Estados Unidos que sigue vigente hasta
nuestros días, y que es el otro pilar fundamental
de la seguridad islandesa.
Desde ese momento y hasta 2006, en Islandia
se desplegó la llamada “Fuerza de Defensa
de Islandia”, que contaba con 1.350 militares
estadounidenses y otros 100 civiles del Departamento
de Defensa de Estados Unidos en la base aeronaval
de Keflavík.
Islandia ya era segura.)
El país de los volcanes impronunciables consiguió
lo que buscaba: explotar su posición geográfica
para conseguir protección.
Pero, no se quedó solamente ahí.
¿Y si os dijera que los gobiernos de Islandia
en esta época fueron algo retorcidos?
¿Y si os dijera que el chantaje fue un método
más que habitual para el gobierno islandés?
Por ejemplo: entre los años 50 y 70, Islandia
se enfrentó a Reino Unido por las zonas pesqueras
en lo que se conoció como “Guerras del
Bacalao”.
Islandia iba ampliando progresivamente sus
zonas sin negociar con Reino Unido y esto
derivaba en fuertes tensiones.
Bien, pues en todo este embrollo, Estados
Unidos nunca se atrevió a posicionarse del
lado británico: la posición geopolítica
de Islandia era demasiado importante para
vigilar de cerca a una Unión Soviética muy
activa en la región.
Ya sabéis, “por el interés te quiero Andrés”…
Así como véis en este mapa fue cómo Islandia
consiguió ampliar de manera salvaje su zona
económica exclusiva y sus zonas de pesca
hasta las 200 millas náuticas.
Y sí, ya sé lo que estaréis pensando…
Pero si ese límite es el que le corresponde
a todos los Estados con costa.
Pues si, no os falta razón, sin embargo,
lo curioso de esta historia es lo rápido
que consiguieron ampliar su zona económica
exclusiva prácticamente por diez.
No obstante, pronto se les iba a acabar el
chollo.
La Unión Soviética cayó y la Guerra Fría
terminó: la amenaza comunista desapareció
de repente y con ella la urgencia estadounidense
de tener una base en Islandia también se
esfumó.
Por eso, desde entonces, Estados Unidos comenzó
a retirar sus tropas de la isla de tal forma
que en 2006 ya no quedaba ninguna bota estadounidense
en suelo islandés.
La Fuerza de Defensa de Islandia pasó a la
historia y la base de Keflavík fue cedida
al gobierno de la isla, que la convirtió
en el principal aeropuerto internacional del
país.
El acuerdo de defensa con Estados Unidos de
1951 continuó en vigor y así sigue estando
hoy, pero ya no hay efectivos militares en
la isla.
Sin embargo, eso no quita a que la marcha
del ejército americano dejase un enorme vacío
de seguridad, al menos psicológicamente hablando,
con una sensación de que el país insular
había perdido toda la relevancia geoestratégica
que tanto supo aprovechar durante décadas.
Y precisamente por esto Islandia comenzó
a actuar.
Reikiavik empezó a hacerse cargo de su seguridad.
Pero, sin un ejército propio, ¿cómo diantres
lo haría?
Pues bien, atentos.
(GÉLIDAS TENSIONES)
Pocas veces encontramos países que han tardado
más de 60 años en legislar sobre la seguridad
de sus territorios como ha hecho Islandia.
La seguridad, suele ser, al fin y al cabo,
una de las prioridades de todo país que quiera
sobrevivir.
Pero la realidad es que a Islandia no le hizo
falta hacerlo hasta que las tropas estadounidenses
se marcharon del país.
Eso sí, una vez que Islandia se dio cuenta
de su nueva realidad, no tardó en tomar cartas
en el asunto: cerró acuerdos de cooperación
con otros socios de la OTAN, creó la Agencia
de Defensa Islandesa en 2008 que se cerró
en 2011 por falta de fondos, aprobó su Ley
de Defensa en 2008 y su Política de Seguridad
Nacional en 2016…
Vamos, que quietos no se quedaron.
Por esa razón, hoy Islandia cuenta con una
Guardia Costera que, aunque existe desde 1918,
nunca ha sido tan grande como lo es ahora,
con unos 200 efectivos entre sus filas, 4
buques y 3 helicópteros medios.
Además, desde la salida de Estados Unidos
se han reforzado las instituciones policiales
del país.
Y, por si fuera poco, Islandia cuenta con
un cuerpo paramilitar, la Unidad de Respuesta
a Crisis, que funciona como una pequeña fuerza
para operaciones de mantenimiento de paz internacionales.
Pero ¡ojo!, porque aún hay más.
Islandia también cuenta con dos activos cruciales
para la OTAN: su Sistema de Defensa Aérea,
que opera 4 complejos radares que sirven como
sistemas de alerta temprana para los aliados
de la OTAN; y su propio territorio y clima,
que son excepcionales para hacer ejercicios
militares especialmente duros conocidos como
“Northern Viking”.
No obstante, un momento.
Hay que ser honestos.
Las capacidades defensivas de Islandia siguen
siendo más bien escasas, sobre todo si quiere
hacer frente a retos de seguridad importantes.
Y esto no es moco de pavo.
Veréis, su reducida capacidad militar es
realmente preocupante si echamos un vistazo
a lo que está sucediendo en uno de los puntos
más próximos a Islandia y que mayor importancia
estratégica lleva ganando estas dos últimas
décadas: estamos hablando, por supuesto,
del Ártico.
(El Ártico, del cual ha os hablado anteriormente
en VisualPolitik, ha ido ganando especial
relevancia en los últimos años por una razón
en concreto: el deshielo.
El mayor derretimiento estival de masas de
hielo está permitiendo que nuevas rutas comerciales
aparezcan y se consoliden.
Al tiempo también se está abriendo la posibilidad
de poder explorar los vastos recursos que
se dice que alberga esta región: hasta un
30% de todas las reservas mundiales de gas
natural y un 13% de las de petróleo.
Es por ello por lo que el Ártico ha ido experimentando
una c reciente militarización de parte de
un actor en especial, de Rusia.
Y es que Rusia tiene grandes intereses en
la región ártica, al fin y al cabo, el 80%
de su gas natural y el 17% de su petróleo
lo produce allí.
Y, es más, el Ártico también da lugar a
la mayor flota naval de Rusia, la Flota del
Norte, al igual que a su mayor salida a mar
abierto.
Por eso, no es de extrañar que Rusia se haya
esforzado en militarizar el Ártico como ningún
otro país, triplicando el número de bases
de la OTAN en la región, algo de lo que ya
os hemos hablado en este canal.)
Pero, como os podéis imaginar, Rusia no es
la única interesada en esta zona.
Es más, China, que no es una nación ártica
como por ejemplo lo son Suecia, Noruega o
la propia Islandia, tiene fuertes intereses
en la región.
Pekín cuenta ya con bases civiles que pueden
servir para sus servicios de inteligencia
justo en estos 3 países.
No obstante, el interés del gigante asiático
en esta zona no está tanto en el terreno
militar, sino sobre todo en el potencial comercial
que tiene.
Y es que, veréis, su principal ambición
en la región es potenciar la Ruta marítima
del Norte, para reducir el tiempo y el coste
del transporte.
Y también por su propia seguridad: con esta
ruta, China puede además asegurarse que los
cargamentos que tiene que recibir en sus puertos
no se ven interrumpidos ni en el estrecho
de Malaca ni en el Océano Índico, donde
tiene multitud de contrincantes, como la propia
India.
Por eso, China ha estado apoyando a Rusia,
a pesar de las sanciones, para hacer que esta
ruta se convierta en una vía realmente estable.
Y claro, en semejante berenjenal no podía
faltar, por supuesto, Estados Unidos.
Es cierto que el interés del tío Sam por
el Ártico ha sido, hasta hace poco, reducido,
pero con la llegada de Trump a la presidencia
el temá comenzó a ganar relevancia.
Por ejemplo, en 2018 se restableció la Segunda
Flota de Estados Unidos, y en 2020 la potencia
norteamericana llevó a cabo más de 20 ejercicios
militares en el Ártico.
Y, por si fuera poco, desde hace poco venimos
encontrando noticias como esta:
(Islandia autoriza la visita de submarinos
nucleares estadounidenses.
Highnorthnews)
Esta noticia, de hecho, es más reveladora
de lo que parece.
Uno podría pensar que el papel de Islandia
en las disputas de grandes potencias en el
Ártico no sería demasiado relevante.
Sin embargo, la realidad es que el papel de
esta isla escasamente habitada y sin ejército
es crucial en todo este puzle estratégico.
O dicho de otra manera, que Islandia ha recobrado
su importancia geopolítica.
Ahora bien, ¿por qué?
Pues descubrámoslo.
(ISLANDIA, GUARDIÁN DE LA BRECHA)
Todos hemos estado viendo este último año
y medio cómo Rusia ha concentrado sus mayores
esfuerzos en invadir Ucrania.
Hay quien podría pensar que incluso ha dejado
de lado otros objetivos geopolíticos, y puede
que así sea, pero desde luego no es el caso
del Ártico.
La región gélida del norte sigue siendo
absolutamente prioritaria para Putin, y por
eso sigue fuertemente militarizada a pesar
de todo.
Claro que, cualquiera podría pensar que perdiendo
tantísimos recursos en Ucrania, en Moscú
no van a estar pensando en el Ártico ¿verdad?
Pues nada más lejos de la realidad.
Esta zona apenas ha visto reducidas las capacidades
militares rusas por mar y aire, y tan solo
un poco en cuanto a las terrestres.
De hecho, esto es lo que hace a los países
de la OTAN y sus aliados estar muy alerta.
Y dado que la presencia rusa en la región
es algo que difícilmente puede ignorarse,
plantarle cara a Moscú de manera directa
no es algo que Islandia se haya planteado
muchas veces.
De hecho, sus relaciones han sido incluso
positivas: por ejemplo, en 2013 se comprometieron
a cooperar más estrechamente en la protección
y la investigación del Ártico.
Además, han llegado a acuerdos en cuanto
a pesca, energía y turismo.
Aunque eso sí, todo esto no les ha hecho
olvidar sus compromisos internacionales.v
Por ejemplo, en 2014 Islandia no dudó en
condenar los abusos de Rusia cuando invadieron
y se anexionaron Crimea, uniéndose también
a las sanciones occidentales a pesar de que
su propia industria pesquera iba a salir perjudicada.
A raíz de eso, por cierto, empezaron a ser
habituales noticias como estas:
(20 de febrero de 2015) Bombarderos rusos
avistados en el espacio aéreo islandés.
Icelandmonitor)
(26 de septiembre de 2016) Islandia denuncia
que los bombarderos rusos suponen un "peligro
para los aviones civiles".
The Guardian)
Y, como ya hizo en 2014, cuando Rusia invadió
de nuevo Ucrania a principios de 2022, Islandia
volvió a condenarlo y a sancionarlo.
Es más, a pesar de no tener un ejército
propio ni poder permitirse el lujo de enviar
soldados al frente, Islandia ha apoyado a
Ucrania de otras maneras: ha donado 3 hospitales
de campaña, les ha comprado 10 camiones de
transporte petrolero y ha acogido a 3.000
refugiados, o bentre otras cosas.
Ahora bien, todo esto no nos dbice mucho de
la renovada importancia geopolítica que os
hemos dicho que ha cobrado Islandia.
Y entonces, ¿de qué va eso exactamente?
Pues, nada más y nada menos que de su posición
central en un espacio muy concreto, la llamada
“brecha GIUK”, por las iniciales en inglés
de Groenlandia, Islandia y Reino Unido.
(La “brecha GIUK” se refiere al espacio
que separa el mar de Noruega del Océano Atlántico
Norte, y que va desde Groenlandia hasta el
Reino Unido, pasando por Islandia.
Esta región tuvo especial relevancia en la
Guerra Fría, ya que se convirtió en un punto
de bloqueo que separaba el espacio de actuación
de la Flota del Norte soviética del espacio
atlántico de la OTAN.
Es decir, funcionaba como una barrera contra
el ejército soviético.
Por esa razón, GIUK se convirtió en uno
de los espacios más vigilados del mundo,
desempeñando Islandia un papel especialmente
importante, ya que gozaba de una visión casi
periférica y de un amplio control de la región.)
El caso es que hoy, querida comunidad de VisualPolitik,
Islandia ha recobrado su relevante papel en
un momento en el que Rusia se muestra claramente
hostil otra vez, con patrullas de submarinos
nucleares y convencionales no solo en la región
del Ártico, sino también en la “brecha
GIUK”.
C1 (“La potencial vuelta a una situación
similar a la de la Guerra Fría, con submarinos
desplegados alrededor de Islandia y con vuelos
de bombarderos estratégicos ahora de nuevo
amenazantes, ha proporcionado a Islandia una
excelente ocasión para concitar nuevamente
el interés militar de Estados Unidos y de
la OTAN”– Alejandro Mackinlay, reservista
destinado en el Estado Mayor de la bbArmada
española en un artículo del Instituto Español
de Estudios Estratégicos.)
Ya lo veis, Islandia es la mejor prueba de
que no se necesita un ejército propio para
tener influencia, estar seguro y prosperar.
Es más, puede que sea uno de los mejores
ejemplos de cómo, jugando bien, incluso con
las peores cartas se pueden hacer milagros.
Islandia ha vuelto al tablero geopolítico
alimentado por un nuevo conflicto entre occidente
y Rusia, y puede que ahora, con un Ártico
fuertemente militarizado por Putin, su papel
sea incluso más fundamental para vigilar
la brecha GIUK que incluso durante la Guerra
Fría.
Pero llegados a este punto la pregunta ahora
es para ti: ¿estamos ante el inicio de otro
largo periodo de relevancia estratégica islandesa?
¿Volverá Islandia a jugar de forma interesada
con sus socios como hizo durante la Guerra
Fría?
¿Pedirán una mayor presencia militar extranjera
frente a una Rusia cada vez más presente
en el Ártico?
Podéis dejarnos vuestras respuestas en los
comentarios.
Y como siempre, si os ha gustado este vídeo
no olvidéis darle like y suscribiros a nuestro
canal.
Y por supuesto, dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de las novedades que estén
por llegar.
Una vez más, muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.